I ordered with more than 100,000 condoms in 2010 for the Winter Olympics in Vancouver, it is clear
- A little extra physical activity goes on during the games. But, does this sexual excitement
Before the competition affect the athletic performance?
Many ancient civilizations, including the Greeks, believed that the semen was divine and
Contained the power of man. Today, some athletes hold the belief that sexual frustration, driven
By abstaining from sex, aggression eventually increases - which is valuable for many sports. Testosterone,
In particular, are responsible for the aggression and sexual desire of men and women, and
There has long been a belief that ejaculation directed the testosterone from the body. Mohammed
Ali, for example, does not make love for six weeks before fighting.
But modern science sees things differently. In fact, many studies have shown exactly
Conversely: Increase testosterone after sex. Go without for more than 3 months, testosterone
Drops to levels that close to the baby. So from a biological perspective, sex may actually be sex
Increased performance, especially in the sport where a little additional aggression can be
Determine the factor - such as cross skating, short track speed skating, or of course hockey.
So what about sex body fatigue out? The truth is that the average sex session
Just burn about 50 calories equivalent ... from running up a few flights of stairs. in a
On the contrary, studies have found that night sex has no noticeable effects before
On strength, energy, endurance, or any other fitness variables. However, sex has been documented
To trigger the release of pain blockers in the brain. These chronic adjustment can help
Pain, with lasting effects up to more than 24 hours.
The biggest unknown lies in the psychological effects, which are much harder to study, and
Has already played a bigger role in major competitions. The best athletic performance is achieved for
With a certain balance of vigilance and anxiety. Of course, stay up all night hunting sexual
Unconscious tips scale against vigilance the next day. On the other hand, sex can be
A great stress statement for nervous athletes. While other characters simply desire more
Focus and focus, in this case, to a good night of sleep is ideal.
At the end of the day, science says: It depends how the sex affects each individual. If you need to
That extra kick of testosterone, you may just want to get the game - early night.
Do not forget: we have a new video every day during the Olympics.
I can not wait? Our amazing partners at CBC already have five videos so far for you to party on.
Just go to cbc.ca/olympics/ScienceSays to see it before anyone else.
Link in description.
But we also want to know your questions for this special series. Use ScienceSays tag and let us know burning your Olympic questions.
Subscribe to the most awesome science videos!